i want to play a little bit of a game
i'm going to call it devil's advocate
which is i'm going to put on the hat of
like all kryptos [ __ ] right like
look like that's the head i'm going to
put on for a second and i want to kind
of walk through a couple pieces of these
and have you uh kind of educate everyone
on why is certain pieces of the
technology superior to the current way
things are done so i think first is uh
when we think of uh kind of the
underlying technology today stocks are
electronic q-sips they're traded through
the centralized entities uh there's you
know one to two days settlement times
etc by moving it into this kind of
digital security realm the skeptic or
the the kind of devil's advocate would
say this is nonsense like the stock
already trades it already settles what's
the problem why do we need to put it
onto a blockchain what would your answer
to that be
well look there's like no brainer
there's no i'm not talking about the
no-brainer stuff and let me talk about
the more sophisticated like uh
exponential power kind of stuff so the
no-brainer stuff is efficiencies across
the system immediate settlement right
instead of t plus two or t plus three uh
things like so for example in our
offering um you can have something like
kyc encoded on the blockchain right so
if you've already gone through kyc if
you've already gone through
accreditation it can live in the
blockchain somewhere and every time you
want to invest in something else you
don't have to go through it again and
again it's actually in the system you're
removing a lot of the slow moving manual
intermediaries but let's talk about like
the network effects that happen when you
combine
different closed-loop loop economic
systems that already exist okay so for
example i'm a consumer company uh for
consumer companies loyalty and reward
companies or programs are one existing
closed loop uh creators and influencers
you might pay them in cash you might pay
them in product you might pay them in
access to stuff that's another closed
loop and then shareholders that's three
different kind of closed-loop economies
for a consumer company when you connect
those together you build like
turbocharged the benefits of each of
those individually right and so we
talked about uh if i plug my wallet into
a website and they know who i am and
that builds loyalty the power that you
have there i'm connecting the creator to
shareholders so today equity
compensation is totally normal in a
company sometimes you'll have big
influencers heavy hitters get equity
like a tom brady with an under armour
for example um but your micro
influencers don't get that opportunity
because it's not scalable with um
security tokens it's it's totally
scalable
we know that from reddit and robinhood
today the and crypto the power that
investments have in creating these
communities so you're unifying um all
these ecosystems to drive all that in a
really powerful way
so when you start to think then about a
business like uh oddity let's say how
big is this business
so the last raise that we did uh was for
one and a half billion dollars to close
earlier this year one and a half billion
yes okay and when you start to think
about that are there numbers or metrics
that you guys share publicly in terms of
users or revenue or anything else for
people to understand kind of like where
does that one and a half billion getcha
or like what does it actually produce
i'll avoid any of the specifics on on us
for the purposes of this but we're
supposed to say we're the fastest
growing um one of our brands el machias
is one of the fastest growing beauty
brands uh in the country we have an um a
new brand spoiled child that launched um
which is digital only so our businesses
um
is important
okay and and then in terms of the way
that you would describe somebody is it
fair to say it's like a holding company
for these various beauty brands or like
or a conglomerate or a platform we're a
tech driven platform uh we have
standalone individual brands that are
powered by our in-house technology right
so we've got
in-house built ai computer vision data
science all of these power these
individual brands but our platform is 30
million plus users there's a stat for
you um that we use we take the data from
all those users in order to drive um
our business through those technology
products and also
amazing physical products so amazing
makeup amazing wellness products as well
that combination has been very strong
for us got it and so when you think
about this um i'm assuming that this is
uh i'm gonna use an example that i would
understand and i think the audience will
understand as well in some way you
almost take an approach of like a ghost
kitchen right where it's like hey we
have a platform we create these
individual brands on the ghost kitchen
world they're virtual so there's no
physical components to it other than we
have one kitchen we pump out food and we
put it in different bags and and we
deliver it you all basically have kind
of a centralized platform or offering
here that's technology enabled and
you're able to kind of power brand after
brand after brand and i'm assuming that
then you get smarter about here's what
this audience wants we can cross-market
we can kind of really get almost
compounding or uh effects from the
success that you've seen in past brands
yeah 100 100 hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time